c'est un rituel que vous ne verrez nulle
part ailleurs aux états unis à flint
ville industrielle déchu pauvre à
majorité noire des résidents commencent
à faire la file au milieu de la nuit
ils doivent encore se fier aux
associations caritatives pour avoir
accès à l'eau potable
renault espère mettre la main sur huit
caisses depuis près de cinq ans il ne
peut pas utiliser l'eau de son robinet
pour se laver
il est hors de question de me voir c'est
tout elle est toxique
en 2014 la ville surendettée de flines
sous tutelle de l'état à privatiser son
réseau d'eau potable pour réduire ses
dépenses s'est approvisionnée dans la
rivière que tous avaient pollué l'eau
corrosive et mal filtré à ranger les
vieilles canalisations
elle arrivait donc dans les robinets
chargé de plomb et pouvait causer des
maladies dont des retards
d'apprentissage chez les enfants
il faut se débarrasser de notre
gouverneur républicain en ce moment il a
caché de l'information sur notre ou
toxiques pendant des années arthur
hunter fait du porte à porte
trois fois par semaine pour les
démocrates il tente de contrer le
désenchantement des électeurs au
présidentielle de 2016 dans notre
empathie le premier républicain en 28
ans a remporté le michigan par à peine
dix mille voix beaucoup d'électeurs se
sont abstenus de voter et le candidat
indépendant a récolté plus de 170 mille
votes
arthur routeur sans que les gens ont un
plus grand intérêt pour les élections
cette fois ci les démocrates qui
pourraient remporter plusieurs des
sièges en jeu ne ménage aucun effort
barack obama est même venu participer à
un grand rassemblement à détroit
vendredi dernier
[Applaudissements]
liane walker a remporté un prestigieux
prix environnemental pour avoir initié
le mouvement citoyen qui a révélé la
crise de l'eau potable à flint la
contamination au plomb semble avoir
engendré des retards d'apprentissage
pour ses deux jumeaux de 7 ans après des
années de promesses brisées liane et ses
amis trouvent difficile de faire
confiance aux politiciens républicains
démocrates si du pareil au même pour eux
gosnat l'entourage du gouverneur
républicain appuie la candidate
démocrate dit il
vous ne trouvez pas ça bizarre pour eux
ce sont les enjeux locaux qui sont
importants
votez démocrate pour contrer quand par
washington à ne les intéresse pas
nos problèmes sont beaucoup plus
pressant que le climat politique
américain ont guéri c'est la santé de
nos enfants qui est en jeu
les résidents de flaine sont divisés les
blancs et les noirs les quelques riches
et les moins nantis les engagés et les
désillusionnés
mais les citoyens de flaine sont aussi
patient et résilients aux menaces a
finalement obtenu ces huit caisses d'eau
il reviendra la semaine prochaine pour
avoir de l'eau et aussi pour aider à
cette distribution ici philippe leblanc
radio-canada flemme